the dumbest know nothing do nothing
never built nothing mother on planet
Earth Dana White from the UFC he's the
president of the UFC we've shown a
couple of his Clips uh over the last
couple months uh here he is just going
off on the media and he Nails it per
perfectly and again he's not he's not a
politics guy he's not a politician he's
a now running a fighting organization
but he gets it better than most of the
pundits I would say especially the the
media if the media tells you you've got
something that that's going to fail it's
definitely going toing win the media are
the dumbest no nothing do nothing
nevering built nothing on
planet Earth so when they say it isn't
going to work you got a fing home run
man you know what I mean jump in and
grind the the the media these guys think
about who these people are when you
really think about the media who are
they where do they come from why does
their opinion matter what have they ever
done what have they ever created what
have they ever built who's ever depended
on a paycheck from the media nobody they
are a bunch of zeros that sit
around and write stories about people
who are actually
doing it's true right like we all know
it's true what does the media actually
create other than chaos look at Elon
Musk we're do some stuff about Elon in
the second half of the show but look at
just the last year with Elon Musk for
the 10 years before that Elon was the
hero of the media right he was sending
Rockets to Mars he was building electric
cars he was doing all of this cool stuff
then and everyone loved him then he
started to take some positions that were
a little against the media mostly
related to free speech which is
ultimately why he bought Twitter uh this
is a guy who by any estimation is still
a I would say old school liberal for the
most part and now they hate him and now
they're constantly worried about say
child porn on Twitter which is an
important thing to worry about but they
didn't care about it before he had
Twitter right so everything they do is
to destroy the people who create why do
they go after Jordan Peterson he's
helping people take care of their lives
why do they go after anyone who creates
anything because that's where the clicks
and the views are and if people start
realizing that you don't need the
government to build your business and
you don't need the government to educate
your kids and a whole bunch more than
uhoh then they're going to be out of
business and they're not in the business
of being out of
business